michel raimbault bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin en
direct sur rt france
arab news nouvelle arme du soft power
saoudien pour conquérir les francophones
selon vous oui parce que je pense que
c'est l'objectif proclamé est recherché
c'est à ce moment c'est de bonne guerre
je dirais de bonne guerre médiatique
parce qu'un matériau soit ouvert jusqu'à
présent enfin le sous le règne de la
douceur de son courage notamment l ami
d'hier et une approche de la presqu'île
étrange il est encore là pour en
témoigner
je pense que l'image de la serbie depuis
le déplacement avec salman taseer itier
est en fait le patron effective de
l'arabie saoudite l'arabie saoudite
une image qui est des gars qui peut
controversé je pensais je crois qu'elle
a perdu toutes ses traditions tous ses
repères quoi je crois que c'est en masse
et les gestes de conciliation sur le
monde je pense que ça peut être bien
accueillie mais ça ne peut pas faire de
mal ça dépote bien alors arab news c'est
une vénérable institution souviens je
crois que tout bien ça presqu'un demi
siècle d'existence disant en anglais
donc c'était le principal c'était le
quotidien de langue anglaise à présent
d'une version numérique en français
c'était quelque chose
la france souhaitait depuis longtemps
mais ça n'avait pas eu trop d qu il a
mis seul depuis samedi
je pense que maintenant c'est fait et
alors pour l'image de marque de l'arabie
saoudite je pense peut-être rattrapé
cette image d' encore une fois l'image
du prince avec man salle même pas
seulement vis-à-vis des journalistes
femmes façon générale sa façon de
concevoir la modernisation d'avis que
j'allais dire n'importe quoi en en
rajoutant un peu dans l'image ça donne
pas une image de ce qu a voir mais c'est
pas tellement finalement jusqu'à présent
laissé de rectifier le tir c'est pas
tellement dans la ligne de la politique
c'est bien traditionnels qui lui donne
une certaine aura
la révision d'un pédiatre
pourtant notamment dans ce mac ou de sa
puissance financière et pétrolière
mais également les pays qui sont à lui
de la france parce que la france huit
membres une arme non seulement peut-être
les baies globalement je pense que
l'arabie saoudite
elle a un rôle dominant au sein de
l'islam en tant que gardienne des saints
et donc je pense que il faut que
l'arabie saoudite je crois c'est que son
intérêt en tout cas de revenir à une
image plus conciliante tests notamment
dans les problèmes moyen-orient du monde
arabo musulman je pense et c'est la
fraude agressif justement la présence
d'armes user dans le paysage
audiovisuel français là c'est bien
évidemment un média en ligne mais ce
qu'elle peut amener une vision
différente du monde musulman qui est
souvent à mal gamme et par vaux avec le
terrorisme
oui j'ai à dire l'arabie saoudite a eu
un rôle à fond je voudrais pas en
rajouter parce que bon je pense que
c'est certainement pas dans l'intérêt du
monde arabo musulman que de minimiser le
rôle mais néanmoins pendant longtemps
l'arabie saoudite tout année dans la
même lignée logique youtube avait uni
qui était modérée et de pacification et
de conciliation de deux intermédiaires
entre tous les courants qui traversent
arabe et musulman or depuis dans la
période récente a cessé et notamment
depuis les printemps arabes alors dû pas
vu de les rapports d'une appendicite
avec terrorisme
je crois que c'est vrai il ya eu quand
même faudra pléa aux comptes a fait
ambiguë et par exemple dans la guerre de
syrie mais dans d'autres guerres
également de la région on s'apprête à un
rôle à la conciliation certainement
notamment pour la der de syrie elle a un
rôle extrêmement agressif qu'on a un bon
moment et maintenant c'est difficile de
réparer les pots cassés et de revenir
sur la scène parce qu'il ya des
pressions de l'occident je dirais sur
l'arabie saoudite notamment des états
unis mais également d'autres pays
probablement de la france et qui empêche
un petit tour y compris la
reconstruction dasri
enfin l'image de marque de l'arabie
saoudite être améliorée par l'ouverture
de sun média arabe ou je ne sais pas
quel sera son audience sur les médias en
ligne ont effectivement défaut d'autre
chose faisait le parallèle avec un autre
véhicule et vous connaissez bien
je sais pas si c'est comparable égard
mais on peut penser que le ballon dans
la france pendant ce qu'elle vend à
l'arabie saoudite et dans les rapports
qu'elle a avec l'arabie saoudite tempère
ravi samedi
je pense à servir à infléchir la
politique saoudienne la caution mais ces
retraits vont très rapidement on a peu
de temps est ce que
l'arabie saoudite cherche également à
concurrencer le 14 on sait que c'est son
ennemi que la chaîne al jazeera et à j +
ont beaucoup d'influencé ce que c'est
une manière aussi de se poser de se
présenter sur cette scène audiovisuelle
je crois que oui parce que seul le qatar
avait précédé la ramie samedi du point
de vue des visuels à l'international
avec djezzy la suite je crois qu'ils
avaient mis sur pied une chaîne une
version francophone disons avant
l'arabie samedi et puis cette grand
rival finalement dans le cadre des
mouvements islamiques y compris de tous
les soutiens tous ces printemps à de
mauvaises renault mais je pense que
l'arabie saoudite représente le pôle
bois vides face aux affaires mouvementée
représenté par le qatar est linéaire le
tueur qui a le rôle que l'on sait merci
beaucoup en tout cas michel raimbault
d'avoir réagi ce matin sur notre antenne
je rappelle que vous êtes essayer ces
anciens ambassadeurs de france